[موسيقى]
البدايه من شرم الشيخ المصريه التي يعقد
فيها اليوم اجتماع خماسي لدعم التهدئه بين
الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي والعمل
على وقف التصعيد المستمر يشارك في
الاجتماع وفد فلسطينيون واخر اسرائيلي
برعايه امريكيه مصريه اردنيه ياتي
الاجتماع استكمالا لقمه العقبه التي عقدت
الشهر الماضي في الاردن
قال تور وينسلندا المبعوث اممي للسلام في
الشرق الاوسط ان القيادتين الاسرائيليه
والفلسطينيه بحاجه لاتخاذ قرارات
استراتيجيه من اجل ان يمر شهر رمضان
الكريم دون تصعيد واضاف في تصريحات لموقع
ولا الاسرائيلي انه من الصعب للغايه
الاتفاق على استراتيجيه لاحتواء التصعيد
بسبب انعدام الثقه بين الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين واوضح المبعوث الاممي ان
تنفيذ تفاهمات اجتماع العقبه يمكن ان
تساعد في دفع الامور بالاتجاه الصحيح
وبشان تنسل الحكومه الاسرائيليه من نتائج
اجتماع العقبه قال وينسوند انه لا يمكن
القول انك لا توافق على ما وقعت عليه وشدد
وينسند على ان ضمان الهدوء والسلام في
الضفه الغربيه وشرق القدس مفتاح للحفاظ
على الهدوء في غزه
وقال كذلك ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه
لاهتماما كافيا لعنف المستوطنين لافتا انه
لا يمكن كذلك تكرار حادثه حواره